[Musique]
bonjour à tous soyez les bienvenus dans
ce numéro de demain à la une les accords
d'evian commémoraient ce samedi en
france signe il ya soixante ans ce pacte
devait ouvrir la voie à l'indépendance
de l'algérie pour sceller la paix mais
la période de transition a été
particulièrement violente
quelles perspectives de paix en en
ukraine alors que le pays est bombardé
sans relâche par l'aviation russe des
voix s'élèvent pour appeler à la
poursuite du dialogue entre moscou et
kiev ce dialogue est il encore possible
de poser la question
l'obsession d'un responsable doit être
de faire avancer la paix et de négocier
une paix durable cette phrase a été
prononcée par dominique de villepin pour
l'ancien ministre français des affaires
étrangères la voie diplomatique et il
restera donc l'une des seule issue
possible à la guerre en ukraine un
plaidoyer est repris et appliquées par
d'autres figures politiques la turquie
s'est par exemple illustré dans cet
effort on en parle avec vous et léna
volochine bonjour l ena merci d'être là
je m'arrête là chef du bureau de france
24 à à moscou merci d'être auprès de
nous aujourd'hui puis gauthier rybinski
bonjour gauthier dit la rédaction de
france 24 merci à tous les deux d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et léna les
deux camps on parlait surtout ces
derniers temps à d'avancer dans les
négociations dans les pourparlers
quelles sont ces avancées de quoi parle
en tout et quelles en seraient les
effets sur tout alors il y a eu la
question des couloirs humanitaires ça
n'a pas marché il ya eu la question de
la neutralité l'ukraine ça ne semble pas
avancé non plus moi mon opinion est que
vladimir poutine ne sera amené à
négocier et en tout cas il accepte de
négocier la partie russe entre dans les
négociations pour dire que l négocié et
que justement elle veut la paix mais de
manière générale ce qu'on observe de ce
que fait la russie c'est que d'un côté
le négocie mais de l'autre côté elle
poursuit avec les armes avec son
opération militaire et quoi qu'elle en
dise elle mène ses opérations jeu
jusqu'au bout tout en disant que c'est
la partie adverse qui fait échouer la
négociation sur le terrain maintenant
moi je pense que la seule issue possible
par la négociation et a mené la russie à
négocier et à appliquer ce qui serait
dit pendant les négociations se seraient
ciblés des meilleures poutines se met à
perdre la guerre c'est à dire que ce
qu'on observe en ce moment militairement
côté russe ce n'est pas fameux elle
semble stagner la russie elle semble
avoir de grandes difficultés sur le
terrain et ça ce serait peut-être
effectivement un espoir pour que
vladimir poutine cherchent une porte
d'issue par la négociation en faisant
semblant que de toute façon c'est lui
qui garde la main qui obtient finalement
ce qu'il veut mais pour moi la seule
voilà la seule marge de manoeuvre d'une
voie diplomatique ce serait seulement si
vladimir poutine n'obtient pas
militairement ce qu'il veut cette issue
diplomatique
il pourrait peut-être l'établir avec
avec le président français parce qu'on a
vu que vladimir poutine elena consentez
à maintenir le contact notamment ou
peut-être même essentiellement que le
président français pourquoi alors le
contact avec le président français tout
comme avec avec le chancelier allemand
ça c'est quelque chose qui relève de ce
fameux format 10 de normandie c'est à
dire que voilà la france l allemagne on
les place en négociateur dans cette
crise avec l'ukraine mais à mon avis
c'est un format de forme qui a
d'ailleurs été relancé à grand peine
tout juste récemment c'est juste pour
dire que voilà les européens ont la main
ont négocié avec les européens et notre
d'autant plus que c'est très difficile
avec les etats-unis le vrai
interlocuteur pour la russie dans cette
crise ça reste je baille donne ça reste
aussi l'otan c'est c'est vraiment pour
pour faire pression sur l'otan que
vladimir poutine a lancé cette guerre
cette guerre en ukraine parce qu on se
souvient des exigences de départ c'était
toujours de dire que la russie que
l'otan menacerait la russie qu'on ne
veut pas que l'ukraine intègre l'otan
qu'on veut une ukraine démilitarisé où
les américains ne joue plus aucun rôle
et c'est donc il faut vraiment pas
perdre de vue le fait que pour la demie
routine l'interlocuteur principal reste
les états unis et donc de ce point de
vue là effectivement il maintient
l'apparence de la diplomatie avec la
france avec emmanuel macron qui lui de
son côté veut en être il veut vraiment
participer à cette négociation c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il se refuse
complètement a qualifié vladimir poutine
de dictateur etc mais si négociations il
ya il ya d'abord les négociations très
concrète et pragmatique qui lie à entre
les russes et les ukrainiens pour voir
qu'est ce qui se passe sur le terrain et
puis sur le plan politique avant tout je
pense que la dîmière plus il veut
discuter avec joe biden et joe biden qui
a pourtant un ton diamétralement opposé
à celui du président français qui vous
le rappeler refuse de qualifier vladimir
poutine de dictateur on va écouter cette
séquence de ces mots même lâché par le
président américain puis on se reparle
juste après notamment avec vous mettiez
[Musique]
je remets un petit peu de contexte on se
souvient à gauthier il ya aussi quelques
mois que le président américain confirmé
une question posée par un journaliste ou
là encore il qualifiait le président
russe de tueurs comment est-ce qu'on
peut expliquer ce que vient dire elena
joe biden est un acteur majeur sur la
scène diplomatique et pourtant il adopte
ce ton là risquent pas de se saborder
ci mais il s'est déjà saborder je veux
dire par là que le fait d'emblée d'avoir
annoncé que ni les américains ni l'otan
interviendrait en ukraine dès le départ
des mêmes avant l'invasion et mamie
immédiatement après l'invasion russe
c'était déjà une façon de se saborder se
saborder ça veut dire aussi que quand on
est loin justement que quand on n'a pas
l'intention d'intervenir on peut se
permettre un certain nombre de choses de
langage si effectivement vladimir
poutine est un tueur comme il l'avait
dit lors de cette interview que vous
rappeliez si vladimir poutine est un
criminel de guerre comme il le dit il
n'y a strictement aucune raison si ce
n'est des raisons effectivement qui
tiennent à la au nucléaire et ça on en
parlera mais logiquement qu'est-ce qu'on
fait d'un criminel de guerre dans le
meilleur des cas on la trappe si
possible vivant mais on ne reste pas les
bras ballants et là c'est au fond c'est
une manière oui de ceux de se mettre
tout nu lui-même job dit voilà je pense
que vladimir poutine est un criminel de
guerre mais je ne ferai rien et par
comparaison est évidemment là l'attitude
du président français macron alors elle
elle découle d'une
d'une arrogance d'une certaine d'un
caractère hautain de la diplomatie
française qui est de croire que on peut
toujours avoir le contact notamment avec
les russes parce que dans l'imaginaire
historique c'est le fameux rouleau
compresseur russe qui datait de la
première guerre mondiale on avait des
liens avec eux souvenez vous aussi que à
travers cette mythologie d'un d'une
liaison slave de la france avec le monde
slave c'est comme ça que françois
mitterrand n'a pas voulu charger les
serbes lors de la guerre alex guerre en
yougoslavie parce que c'était lié avec
les russes et une fraternité d'armes
tout ça c'est possible alors le résultat
c'est que quand même si ça permet de
maintenir une marge une passerelle entre
le kremlin et le reste du monde pourquoi
pas mais de toute manière l'idée est que
il ne faut pas et c'est ça qui est
profondément dangereux j'y reviendrai
plus tard c'est qu'il ne faut pas
considérer vladimir poutine comme étant
victime de ses affects je ne dis pas
qu'il est à 100 % victime de ses affects
mais tu dis qu'il n'est pas non plus
diriger est régi par 100% de rationalité
une matérialité et ça c'est ce qu'on
considère autre choix qu'on a considéré
qui nous plombe aujourd'hui et c'est ce
que fait aussi emmanuel macron en dix
ans le personnage de poutine est
accessible à une forme de raison c'est
possible mais ce n'est qu'une partie du
personnage et à partir de là bas il
reste il reste l'autre moitié est celle
là on a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
mal à l'appréhender et on l'avait
justement plusieurs reprises agité la
menace nucléaire si les russes parce
qu'on a l'impression qu'ils avancent
mais il s'enlise en même temps en tout
cas cette guerre est parti pour
s'installer dans le temps je crois et
c'est peut-être aussi votre analyse et
elena qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent faire
qu'est-ce que peut décider le kremlin
finalement s'il ya un moment une sorte
d'impasse qui s'impose aux autres ou
plus c'est à dire que on part du
principe que voilà vladimir poutine
c'est quelqu'un qui veut une négociation
pour éviter le pire à tout prix ce n'est
pas le cas vladimir poutine c'est
quelqu'un et il l'a dit d'ailleurs à la
présidence française on l'a entendu de
l'elysée vladimir poutine a dit
j'arriverai à mes fins par tous les
moyens possibles par la négociation ou
par les armes et on sait qu'ils
privilégient les armes parce que comme
je disais même si mme négocié il dit
qu'il s'engage à faire des choses ou
plutôt ils exigent de la partie adverse
qu'elle s'engage à faire des choses
qu'elles s'engagent à faire mais que lui
ensuite viol en disant que c'est la
partie adverse qui l'a violée si vous
voulez je parle très concrètement
d'opérations militaires comme des
bombardements pendant cessez le feu etc
où il dit nous les russes on s'engage à
respecter le cessez le feu et ensuite
ils ne le font pas en accusant la partie
ukrainienne leur maintenant comme vous
le disiez il s'enlise effectivement la
situation sur le terrain commence à
devenir compliqué
il ya plusieurs facteurs à cela il ya
les analystes ont expliqué des experts
militaires que la russie avait eu un
très mauvais timing en lançant cette
opération au moment du dégel des sols
lorsque les temps commence à s'embourber
lorsqu'ils sont obligés d'emprunter les
axes routiers or vous ne faites pas une
guerre en faisant rouler des tanks sur
des routes parce que les colonnes sont
très facilement localisables et qu'elles
se font pilonné parce que vous avez des
gros problèmes d'approvisionnement de
maintenance de logistique ça séduit la
chaîne de commandement qui est
défaillante malgré toute cette puissance
et cette force de frappe qu'on a
l'habitude de voir et à l'est par la
russie tout ça c'est de la communication
on a investi ces dernières années dans
les nouvelles armes dont des missiles à
à courte à courte et moyenne et longue
portée dans de l'artillerie dans de
l'aviation oui on a des armes mais on a
tout le reste qui manque en réalité est
aussi les forces vives parce que les
soldats russes y sont restés dans ces
camps de fortune à la frontière ils ont
passé un rude hiver là ils sont
concentrées là depuis l'année dernière
et donc qu'ils sont déjà entrés en
guerre fatigués et on a une force une
ressource humaine qui entrait en ukraine
qui doit être relevé or la relève elle
est déjà toute la force vive la force de
combat rue c'est-à-dire des troupes qui
sont potentiellement amenés à combattre
elles sont déjà en ukraine et alors est
ce qui pourrait aller plus loin est ce
que le nucléaire puisque ce vladimir
poutine jusqu'au boutiste ce qu'on peut
aller jusque-là gauthier ce que la
dissuasion ne marche plus alors c'est
vrai qu'on se rend compte d'une une
sorte d'impasse dans cette affaire parce
que qu'est ce que veut dire la
dissuasion nucléaire au sens où elle a
été créée depuis le début de la guerre
froide c'est à dire au sortir de la
deuxième guerre mondiale ça voulait dire
que de part et d'autre on avait des
acteurs qui étaient on va dire
conservateurs entre guillemets c'est à
dire que l'un comme l'autre n'acceptez
pas la destruction de leurs camps pour
les états unis mais de même pour l'union
soviétique ce qui avait été à la tête de
l'union soviétique espérer que cet état
dit prétendument des ouvriers et des
paysans seraient éternels inaltérable
donc y avait un avantage conservé
quelque chose que devient la dissuasion
nucléaire quand on ne sait pas à qui on
a affaire c'est-à-dire avec à vladimir
poutine qui de par un certain nombre de
témoignages et même de recoupements et
quelqu'un qui peut être habité par une
vision apocalyptique
qu'est-ce qu'on fait du nucléaire dans
ce cas là et vous le voyez bien le
nucléaire ne sert à rien parce que ce
qui aurait pu se passer cette fois ci
c'est qu'on mette eux sans rire me
nucléaire six personnes avait une arme
nucléaire andré libyen l'otan intervient
pour éliminer la russie et les troupes
russes 2 du territoire ukrainien points
or ça n'est pas possible parce qu'on
sait très bien que s'il y a quelque
chose de cet ordre là c'est le feu
nucléaire absolu et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je termine là dessus vous avez
vu ces sept obus qui était tombé pas
loin de la frontière polonaise vos rêves
s'il était tombé du côté polonais le
secrétaire de l'auto-stop une berg
aurait dit oui il faut intervenir et
quand il a appris que cet audit avait
été véritablement avait touché la la
partie ukrainienne il a dit si ça terry
la police il faudra que nous envisagions
de considérer la question c'est à dire
un déplacement de rhétorique et surtout
de raisonnement voilà toute la gravité
de la chose le nucléaire est la
dissuasion aujourd'hui ne servent pas à
grand chose tant qu'il ya de l'autre
côté quelqu'un dont on ne connaît pas
les réelles intentions merci beaucoup
crié merci encore helena merci à vous
marc une courte pause on se retrouve
dans quelques minutes
[Musique]